- It's very airy, and it's
kind of melts in your mouth.
Hi, guys, it's Rie.
Today I'm going to show you three
very different kind of cheesecake.
Some of them are a little bit challenging.
Don't worry, there are
some hacks that help you
make perfect cheesecake.
First, Japanese souffle cheesecake.
First, I want to prep cake pan.
I'm using six inch springform pan.
I'm going to grease my pan so
the parchment sticks better.
I'm gonna use knife to cut.
(parchment ripping)
(parchment crinkling)
Springform pan come with two piece,
and we are going to use
water bath cooking method.
If you put in a water,
there is a gap and water
comes into the pan,
so I'm going to use aluminum foil.
I think springform pan
it's better for this cake
so you can easily remove from the pan.
Now the most difficult part it's done,
let's get to the fun part.
First I'm adding cream cheese,
butter, and heavy cream.
We are going to use double boiler.
So you are going to mix
until evenly smooth.
I'm going to set this aside
and I'm going to separate
egg whites and egg yolk.
And I'm going to add egg yolk in here.
Nice color.
(whisk tapping bowl)
And one tablespoon of lemon juice.
Usually half lemon makes
one tablespoon lemon juice.
Now I am going to sift corn starch.
I enjoy baking a lot.
Of course, my favorite
part it's like eating.
(Rie laughing)
This is already pretty smooth,
but I want to make it extra smooth,
and make sure there's
no cream cheese chunks.
I'm going to put this in
the refrigerator to chill,
so it will incorporate
better with my meringue.
I have egg whites.
(beaters running)
I'm going to add sugar gradually.
It's kinda like in between
soft peak and hard peak.
So this it's the mixture I made earlier.
I'm going to take about
1/4th of the meringue,
incorporate it well.
The first mix it's done,
and I'm going to add all
the rest of the meringue.
And I try not to over
mix here, but make sure
there is no meringue
white stream it's visible.
Now I'm going to add this in a mold.
Yeah, a nice ribbon.
And I'm gonna just tap,
so there's no big bubble.
I use paper towel underneath it
so doesn't give a direct heat.
Pour hot water about halfway
of the springform pan.
Oven temperature is a
very important factor
for this cheesecake.
When I tested it cracked so many times,
so first we are going
to bake this lower heat.
250 for 60 minutes,
increase the heat for 325
and bake for 10 minutes.
Let's go to the oven.
This cake it's baked.
You want to eat right away, right,
but this cake it's taste better
if you chill in the
refrigerator at least two hours
or preferably overnight.
I'm gonna unmold.
Reveal.
I'm brushing apricot jam,
just make the top shiny.
And here we have it,
Japanese souffle cheesecake.
Look how pretty they are.
Can't wait to have a bite.
(upbeat music)
It's really light,
but kinda still have like
nice cheesecake flavor,
just like taste of my childhood.
And I think this is very different
and very good contrast from
the cheesecake I'm making next.
Let's do it.
We are on to the American cheesecake,
and I think the best
part, it's the bottom,
everyone is nodding here.
(people laughing)
All right, so let's get started.
First, we have 12 graham
crackers made into crumbs.
One stick butter, combine well.
All right, I'm using a
nine inch springform pan.
Grease.
(spraying grease)
I'm going to add crumbs.
Dry cup measurement, it's
a perfect things to use.
Kind of press.
I think that's good.
So we are going to bake this at 350 degree
for 20 minutes and let it
cool for room temperature.
I'll be right back.
- [Woman] Woo, oh that was pretty good.
- Now I'm going to make fillings.
First I'm going to crack eggs,
and I'm going to use four eggs.
(eggs cracking)
I have 24 ounces cream cheese.
Add sugar and cream together.
I'm going to add egg one by one.
(beaters running)
I'm going to add vanilla extract.
Batter is ready and crust is ready.
I'm going to use foil
technique that I showed you
for our Japanese cheesecake,
so the water doesn't get in.
We are going to use water bath technique
instead of just baking in the oven,
so it's foolproof, so it won't crack.
Now I'm going to add piece of paper towel,
put the pan in, and add
the batter, and shake it.
And I'm going to add hot water.
And we are going to bake
this at 350 for one hour,
or the center it's slightly still giggly,
but outside it's kind of set.
Let's go.
So I baked this cheesecake
and let it chill
for 12 hours to overnight.
And I'm going to just decorate.
I like decorating, I
think it's kinda nice,
gives a nice pop.
I like to add mint, kinda filling the gap.
Here we have it, American cheesecake.
It's very rich and it's very dense.
Nice contrast with the crust underneath.
I think adding fresh fruits,
it gives a nice contrast
with rich cream cheese
to fresh fruits.
This cheesecake is great, but
next one it's very exciting.
The last cheesecake we are
making is basque cheesecake.
This is known as a burnt cheesecake,
so you are going to bake
it like super high heat.
And this one, it's super easy to make.
I have a two pounds of cream cheese
and I'm adding sugar.
(beaters running)
Okay, I think this it's nice and creamy,
and all the sugar it's
dissolved and incorporated.
I'm going to add eggs one by one.
So first egg.
(beaters running)
Scrape the side.
I'm going to add two cups of heavy cream,
and make sure it's room temperature,
and I'm going to add slowly.
And I'm gonna add two teaspoon of vanilla,
and one teaspoon of salt.
(beaters running)
I'm going to sift flour.
And if you have a stand mixer
you can totally use the stand mixer.
(beaters running)
All right, batter it's done,
and I'm going to prepare my mold.
All right so basque cheesecake hack.
Basque cheesecake you want to
crumble the parchment paper,
but it's difficult to line if you crumble,
it kind of have a gap,
and it doesn't lying well.
But if you soak in a
water, it's easier to line.
So first we are going to crumble.
(parchment crinkling)
And soak in the water.
Paper kinda become a little bit flexible.
A little bit moisture it's fine,
it doesn't affect anything for the cake.
I'm gonna just pour.
So I'm going to bake this at 400 degree
for 50 to 60 minutes.
The top is dark brown and the
center part is kind of jiggly,
but it will set as it cooled,
so don't worry about it.
Let's bake this.
All right, we baked it and let it cool
to room temperature, and look at this.
It is pretty dark brown,
this is what you want.
The color is very unique
and also the texture,
it's the most beautiful thing
about this basque cheesecake.
If you are beginner baker,
I think this it's best cheesecake
to try for the first time,
because you just mix it and
bake in high temperature.
You don't need to worry about cracking,
'cause you want it burnt.
You will gain a confidence.
I like how rustic this look.
Let's unmold.
(parchment crinkling)
Ooh.
Kinda smell like a little
bit caramelized smell.
(upbeat music)
Mm, so different, unreal.
So it kinda like s'more.
You want to burn marshmallow, right.
I made three different cheese cake today.
Japanese souffle cheesecake,
American cheesecake,
and basque cheesecake.
I hope you guys enjoy watching this video.
If you make any of those cheesecake,
tag me on Instagram,
and see you next time.
Thank you for watching.
- [Man] Oh, yes.
(upbeat music)